the jurgen experience but it had to be
really odd to be working that much and
be a young
girl the balance it trained me to have
is something that i don't think you are
going to get taught
any other way besides jumping in the
deep end of the pool and hoping you know
how to swim that's the only way
i there was no way i could have prepared
for the amount of
balance i would have to learn to kind of
teeter because
you know at one point again it went from
it was school
then it went from you know how many
how much we can actually smoke and still
play a teenage superstar on the disney
channel
and then like and then like what's the
answer to that question
more than you would [ __ ] think um i
remember one time when
and i don't smoke anymore and i'm sober
how long have you been sober but i i've
been sober since the
pretty much the vocal surgery kind of
did it for me um
because i just learned so much about the
effects which again you're just not
taught
um it's not really the drinking it's
staying up all night you know once you
have your drink you end up smoking
and i kind of i have um
i've become the face of a lot of things
kind of against my
will i guess from my opinions when
you're
someone in my position your opinion
becomes your identity and it also
becomes
kind of almost like uh you kind of
become this like preacher
you become this you know they don't
really let you just always have your own
opinion so i've decided to start telling
people
i live my own lifestyle alcohol was
never my problem
there was other things that i end up you
know
i like to go up so i i now just avoid
really drinking because i i like to wake
up at 110
um but it's never really been my problem
and i could see myself having a drink of
celebration in the future but
i get so [ __ ] hungover now that i'm
like why would i celebrate with like
just feeling like a volcano's erupted in
my brain you know so
so it's really just a personal
preference but it's definitely not
anything that i promote in
i think it's a lifestyle everyone should
be i think everyone should experiment
it's a good time and you learn a lot of
things about yourself and
the people around you but now i'm
watching i have younger siblings and
they're going through that and i don't
know how my mom did it with me because
it's scary
yeah i don't think i think if we're
going to acknowledge the fact that all
these things exist cocaine exists pills
exist marijuana exists
we should teach people how to do it
right yeah really i mean you're leaving
children it's the same thing with sex
right
yeah we leave children to their their
theirs
the information that they're going to
get is from other kids yeah and if
you're learning about sex from another
14 year old or you're learning about
coke from a 14 year old
that's not good yeah like someone we
we play this game with children where we
try to pretend
that you know they live in a movie all
right well listen to this it's actually
funny you bring this up because i had
the idea this week not that i really
have time to do this in the near future
but i would like to at some point in my
life
i want to do my own children's
book series of realistic children
stories
because i don't like the idea that we
teach them that this is sunshine world
and everyone walks on a rainbow and
everyone's equal and you need to say
like that's not what are you going to do
about it that's not true what are you
going to do about it
and i think there's a way to not terrify
children of life even though
i go in and out of periods where i think
life is really overwhelmingly terrifying
um and that's coming from my position
and my position i
i tell myself all the time if you're not
enjoying this life honey you got it
coming in the next one because i better
[ __ ] love this life
it's the best one i i couldn't imagine
being in a different body and having a
different experience it's an awesome
life if you do it the right way
it's an awesome life and i also i didn't
hurt myself beyond
repair in my experiences i
survived and i don't even mean heart
still beating survival i mean
i have a lot of people that love me
around i didn't kick all the people that
had my best interest at heart out
that's the that's where you die is you
kick everyone
that says hey are you are you okay you
know out
no of course i'm okay you don't trust me
get the [ __ ] out and so now that i have
people that i've had in my life i feel
that i have people in my life that i've
known for
15 20 years and not many people in my
position get to say that
my parents are awesome my dad's loopy as
hell but i
love him so much